This video is brought to you by Nord VPN and their special cyber deal.
Every purchase of a two year plan gets you 68% off,
plus an additional month for free and a surprise gift.
How far would you go to right a wrong,
to correct an injustice to do what your conscience insists must
be done for Roger casement,
this journey took him to darkest Africa and the jungles of Peru.
Some of the most primitive areas on earth were supposedly civilized.
Europeans committed the most heinous crimes against their inhabitants.
All in the name of profits for this,
he was lauded as a hero and given a Knight to its best.
His conscious then sent him to a much darker place.
His desire to free his own country of islands from British rule led him to
collaborate with Britain's world war one, enemies, and ultimately to rebellion.
[Inaudible].
Roger David casement was born on September the first 1864 in Dublin,
Ireland to a Protestant father and to Catholic mother,
captain Roger casement of the British army as the former and Jefferson after his
mother's death in 1873, the family moved to County Andrew.
And what is now Northern Ireland? Four years later, his father died in casement,
was sent to Liverpool to live with the family.
It was maternal aunt grace banister. After finishing school.
He joined a shipping company as a Clark and in 1884,
he secured a position as a purser on a ship to Africa.
He made three more trips within a year.
He fell in love with the exotic land Seesaw and joins the African international
association as a severe mapping regions of the dark continent. Previously,
unknown to Westerners,
Unbeknownst to casements at the time was that the African international,
it was a friend's company for King Leopold.
The second of Belgium magazine in his private interests nods on behalf of the
Belgian government. There was rubber in the Congo to feed the launch endeavor,
increasing demand for bicycle and automobile tires.
And for many other industrial uses while they are casement became friends with a
young riverboat pilot named Joseph caused any of ski,
even sharing accommodations for a time because any officer said that meeting
casement was one of the few good things that had happened to him.
While in Africa later,
Joseph would shortened his name and Anglicised it as Joseph Conrad.
And he wrote the best known book of that period in the Congo heart of darkness,
in which the Ambra Kurtz is a greater Savage than any citizen of Africa.
Casement soon learns many of the local languages. And in 1892,
he went to work for the Nigeria coast protectorate, where he, again,
served as a surveyor. And you know, the posts,
his reports from the region earns him appointments to the foreign office.
After a spell in England, recovering from illness, he was sent to West Africa
In 1895, a man named Charles Stokes,
a British citizen was convicted of illegally selling guns to Africans and was
hanged. The next day, when this news reached person,
it caused such an outcry that's casements by then console Bomer,
and the Congo free state was instructed to compile a detailed report of the
situation. If you've seen our video on King kingdom, Paul,
the second of Belgium,
you know what he found the Belgiums had forced the indigenous population into
slavery and we're systematically working them to death. Leopold's private army.
The force public was responsible for beating production quotas.
It ultimately grew to nearly 20,000 men.
Hostages would taken their lives linked to the amount of rubber gathered.
If it was insufficient, they could be killed.
One frequent punishment was the amputation of the right hands. Originally,
this was intended to keep down costs.
Leopold insisted the bullets should not be wasted.
He insisted that each shot should kill. So if every bullet fives,
the right-hand of the victim was returned as proof.
If the shooter failed to kill its target or simply missed,
they still owed Leopold. A right hands.
One would be taken from whoever was nearby.
Large baskets of separate hands became a common site.
Whipping and mutilation were common punishments for even small offenses.
Killings were frequent in some areas due to violence and disease.
The population declines by more than 90% over 10 years and
compiling his report. Casement relied not only on what he himself hadn't seen,
but gathered over 20 pages of eyewitness testimony about what was occurring in
the Congo.
It was one of the first documents of human rights abuses in the less developed
worlds. And it marks the beginning of the end of the Congo free state.
Its publication was met with outrage throughout Europe and the United States.
And there was a great pressure on Leopold in Belgium.
A commission was formed to look into the charges and it confirms them.
And in 1908, the Congo free state was purchased from the polls by Belgium.
And the worst of the offenses came to an end for his work.
Casement was named to the order of Saint Michael and Saint George.
He returns to islands on the even 1904 and would remain there for over a year.
It was then that he began to show an interest in Irish nationalism,
perhaps the accesses of colonialism that had seen awakened a desire to be free
of English overlord ship. By this time,
Ireland had been ruled by English Kings for almost 400 years,
but still retained an independent cultural identity.
And many of the Irish wished for an independent political identity as well,
casement would soon be among them.
He joins the Gaelic league and encouraged the use of the Irish language.
And in 1905 joins a new political party called shin Fein dedicated to an Ireland
free of British
Basement, resumed his career with the foreign office in 1906.
He was sent to Brazil where he held a number of positions before finally
becoming console general in Rio de Janeiro in 1909.
He received reports of the mistreatment of natives in the upper reaches of the
Amazon river, near the Peruvian city of a ketose. Once again,
the cause was the thriving trade in rubber.
Most of the population of Peru was located on the Western coast of South
America, between the Pacific ocean and the Andes mountains.
It keep those lay on the Eastern side of the Andes in the Amazon rainforest.
It was so that rather than this area was shipped eastward down the Amazon nearly
2000 miles to the Atlantic ocean.
And it can you tell us the Peruvian governments listen to authority.
Instead the Peruvian Amazon company exercised control.
It was a British from the board of directors and many stockholders were all
British, but it was run by Julio says Araunah Peruvian citizen.
Some of those mistreated were citizens of Barbados and therefore of the British
empire, which gave casements a reason to intervene.
He traveled to the region in both 1910 and 1911. Once again,
compiling a thorough report of abuses. It was much the same as in the Congo,
the distance from governments, authorities,
you might intervene meant that the PAC could do what it wished with.
Just impunity. Again, casement wrote of what he saw,
personal onions of what he heard from those who had been victimized.
One common punishment stood out.
People had their head and hands confined in wooden stocks and will have to
standing there for days at a time. Sometimes until they died,
whole families perished this way around his company was dissolved in 1911
though. He was never punished.
He later had a successful political career winning election to the Peruvian
Senate
In 1911, casement received a knighted for his work in the Congo and Peru,
two years later, he returned to Ireland. Soon.
He took up the political activities had begun eight years earlier.
He had arrived as an important juncture a year earlier.
The governing liberal party had lost their majority in the British parliament.
And in order to form a government that enlisted the aid of the Irish
parliamentary party in return for this support,
they promised home rule to Ireland, including its own parliaments,
but British rule was popular in the mostly Protestant counties in the North and
to safeguards to their ties to Britain,
the Ulster volunteers were founded a paramilitary organization,
eventually numbering 100,000 men in response.
Casements helped organize a rival force in the South, the Irish volunteers,
which grew to twice that size. He traveled to the United States in July, 1914,
in order to raise money to buy weapons while there he was fated by the Irish
American community and mess with numbers of clam, the Gale,
a secret society of Irish Republicans,
but as Johnny was singing overtaken by events.
[Inaudible].
Okay. Kaseman was in America at Bosnians named Carrillo, Princip assassinated,
grand jete, Franz Ferdinand, Zara parents.
The Austro-Hungarian empire within weeks,
Europe had stumbled into the most violent war it had ever known in this
conflagration casements or an opportunity. Britain now had a powerful enemy.
One whose aims aligned with his own.
He arranged to meet with the German ambassador to the United States,
counter Johann Heinrich, Von bernstorff, and he made him an offer.
If Germany would supply weapons to the Irish rebels,
they would take islands out of the war.
It was an opportunity that the Germans couldn't ignore as that little to lose,
they were already fighting.
The British on rest in Ireland would distracts them into revolution that would
ease the pressure on the front. And also the casement traveled VASH ship Fest,
Norway, then on to Germany,
he met with German officials and requested enough arms and men's free islands
from British rule.
He arranged for all Irish prisoners to be moved to a camp near Limburg,
his efforts hampered by the Germans in ability to tell Irish from English,
he visited them that and called upon them.
So join the Irish brigades do throw off British rule. As of 2000 men,
90 56 were persuaded. The rest forced him into a hasty retreat.
When returning from a visit to the German headquarters,
he passed by the town of van den in Belgium,
where he sold the graves of 350 civilians who had been executed by the Germans.
He later wrote in his diary, all that the Belgians now suffer that King,
his government and his offices wreaked on the well nigh,
defenseless people of the Congo basin. He worked in Germany for 18 months,
but in the end, a little to show for it.
Casements eventually lost faith in his hosts,
writing this that only interestingly and exploiting me and the Irish cause no
German soldiers would fight in Ireland.
There would be no German officers to lead the Irish brigade.
The 100,000 rifles that had been promised were reduced to 20,000 captured
Russian weapons and a million rounds of ammunition, only 50 rounds per gun.
Now just before we get into the rest of today's video,
let me take a quick moment to tell you about today's fantastic sponsor,
Nord VPN. Look, if you're online, you really should be using a VPN.
And that's when Nord VPN comes in and was tempting not to Obama.
So we just hope for the best, but really those stories you read of people,
having their identity stolen, their data stolen,
it does happen and you don't want it to be easy for that to be you,
whether it's a nefarious actor,
snipping for your private information or a company tracking your activity,
but using a VPN can move out so much more. For example,
North VPN lets you access to any of its thousands of servers in different
countries, all around the globe. So if you've hit the end of your Netflix queue,
simply try changing the location of your server to get access to content
libraries that due to licensing arrangements are only available in specific
geographic locations. Nord VPN is also super fast.
So watching video is a breeze, no lag whatsoever.
If you've ever used VPNs and thought they were slow, well,
no more with Nord and you can use it on all of your devices. Very easily.
Android Chrome windows,
Lenox sand on six different devices with just one accounts.
Also they use double data encryption for extra security and they have this thing
called a kill switch. So if for whatever reason,
you connect to the internet and nor VPN isn't running,
they'll kill your internet until they've ensured that you're on a state
connection. And if you ever get stuck,
they've got 24 seven support to help you out. Take advantage of North specials,
sign the deal.
Every purchase of a two year plan gets you 68% off plus an additional month
for free and just surprise gifts.
[Inaudible].
Well, these guns and ammunition it already to policy for Ireland's a,
a German ship disguised as the Norwegian freighter SS AWD casement realized that
without a large well-armed force, the Easter rising was doomed to fail.
So he decided he must warn the men preparing in Ireland,
the Germans that arranged for a submarine to accompany the Ord.
And so casement traveled to Ireland board. You 19.
The old was intercepted by the Royal Navy off the Southwest coast of Ireland and
forced to sail, to Queenstown under escort. As they entered cork Harbor,
the crew scuttled, the ships sending the arms and ammunition to the bottom.
Casement himself,
went to shore at trainee Bay in County Kerry on the night of the 21st of April
three days before the uprising was to begin,
the companions were able to land on a beach and a collapsible wooden boat.
But during the trip from Germany,
casement had fallen ill with a recurrence of malaria,
which had contracted during his time in the tropics, as he was unable to travel,
the other men helped him to a shelter at an ancient fortification Gordon
McKenna's force,
where he was later found by the local constabulary and arrested from jail.
He insisted upon speaking to a priest and was allowed to see father Frank Ryans,
whom he passed a message counseling. The uprising father,
Ron finally delivered the message on Monday the 24th.
But by then it was too late.
Casement was taken to London while being interrogated by Reginald hall.
Chief of Naval intelligence casement realized that all knew that the uprising
was imminent.
He begged hall to allow him to call it off and avoid unnecessary bloodshed.
But hall refused preferring to crush the rebels.
He said it is better than a conquering saw. Like this should be cut out.
The Irish Republicans fought tenaciously and hung on longer than anyone could
have expected. But by Saturday it was all over. As casement had foreseen,
there'd been outnumbered and tout guns though.
They put up a tenacious defense in the ends.
They were unable to resist the British army. After perfunctory trials,
14 of the rebels were executed by firing
Straw for trees and began on June the 26th.
The prosecution witness included men who Kaseman to try to recruit from the
German prisoner of war camp,
who testified that he asked them to join his Irish brigade as well as the
policemen from Shirley Bay,
who gave evidence about his arrival in capture no less a person than playwright.
George Bernard Shaw urged casement to use his defense,
to make the case for Irish home rule and even prepared a text for him to use
case men considered this.
But in the end was persuaded to allow his lawyer to argue that by the wording of
the law, the statute from the time of Edward, the third,
he had committed no crime. His lawyer,
Alexander Martin Sullivan argued that the law prohibited actions against the
King only in his realm, great Britain and the toll of casements,
admittedly treasonous act to cut in Germany. This strategy back father,
the court after examining the 500 year old document determined that there was a
calmer in the text that meant his actions against Britain treasonous,
anywhere in the world. Before the lawyers began,
the summations casement was allowed to read a statement to the court.
He said that he had gone from Germany, not to England,
but to islands and that any crimes had committed had been done there.
And that if he were to be tried by a jury of his peers,
it should be an Irish jury. Deliberations were brief in less than an hour.
Casement was found guilty of treason.
It's difficult to see how the jury could have decided otherwise by his own
admission, he had conspired with his country's enemy. During war time,
there was this old, he could say in mitigation,
the judges Dawn's the black caps that meant a death sentence and pronounced that
Roger would hang casement was formerly stripped of his nighters.
On June the 30th.
He filed an appeal which was heard on July the 17th after a day and a half of
testimony. It was rejected.
[Inaudible].
Well sympathy for casements. In many quarters due to his humanitarian work,
his friends are Arthur Conan Doyle circulated a petition for clemency that was
signed by GK Chesterton, John Goldsworthy, and many other prominent people.
George Bernard, Shaw Aaron's poet, William Butler, Yeats,
each of whom would go on to receive the Nobel prize for literature were
steadfast in that support one man who was not was casements old friends,
Joseph Conrad, whose son Borys was serving at the fronts. In addition,
the British had to consider the public opinion,
especially in the United States though, officially neutral.
The U S was generally friendly to Britain,
but casement was very popular that in 1912,
he'd met president Taft ans on his later trip to raise money for the Irish
volunteers had made many friends,
the large Irish American community that was sympathetic to his course.
He was compared favorably in the press that 19th century abolitionist John Brown
executed for his attempt to lead a slave uprising.
The Easter rising had been covered extensively by the U S newspapers,
April the 29th, New York times.
It included no fewer than 18 separate items about it.
Doyle's petition mentioned that casements execution would be used as a weapon
against us in the United States and press Baron.
William Randolph Hearst used his newspapers,
the San Francisco examiner in the New York morning journal to urge that the
death sentence be commuted to life in prison. But in Britain,
public opinion was dead set against him. On July. The first,
the British had launched their main attack for 1916 across the som river in
Northwestern, France times to collide with attacks by its allies.
It succeeded in pushing back the Germans,
but at a horrific cost on the first day of the battle,
nearly 20,000 British troops were killed. And twice that number wounded,
there was little sympathy.
[Inaudible].
Kaseman was a gay man in a time when homosexual acts were crimes queen
Victoria's reign ended with a death in 1901,
but the force of Victorian morality, it was undiminished.
All school walls had been imprisoned for gross and decency 20 years before.
And even 40 years later,
Codebreaker ran and tiering was convicted of the same offense and forced to take
hormone treatments leading to a suicide. After casements arrest,
a set of diaries was found among his belongings.
These diaries contained a record of a sexual encounters going back many years
and explicit language.
The British governments had photographs made of a number of pages.
And these were quietly circulated among those concerned, in the case,
including Doyle shore, the Archbishop of Canterbury and King George,
the fifth American ambassador Walter Page was shown the diaries.
He wrote to Washington, this much information about him,
of an unspeakably filthy character was withheld from publicity.
Doyle at least was unimpressed. So told her the diary is content.
So you said no possible sexual offense could be as bad as supporting soldiers
from their duty. But in those days,
homosexuality provoked a sort of discuss that Millie betraying your country
apparently did not in the end, Doyle straw and others were not deterred,
but many who learned the details of his private life changed their opinions of
the man and may have tipped the balance towards his execution.
[Inaudible].
Though consumed with Wallwork the British cabinet discuss casements fate no less
than five times after its conviction.
The contents of the black diaries appear to have eased the moral qualms.
Some had about executing him in the meeting on August. The second,
it was decided that there would be no reprieve.
Casement was informed that it would be hanged in the next day,
that night he converted to Roman Catholicism in the morning he received the only
he would ever hear.
Then he was taken to the gallows and hanged by the neck until dead later,
his body was placed in an unmarked grave in the grounds of Pentonville prison
covered in quick lime and buried Island finally won its independence.
Five years later,
the counties of Northern Ireland chose to remain a part of Britain.
Casements had been asked to be buried in Ireland,
but it wasn't only 50 years before his body was returned to the Island of his
birth.
Even then it was not entered in his family home of County Antrim as the burial
of a martyr of the Irish rebellion,
then lawless Northern Ireland would be politically dangerous and could be
considered as a deliberate provocation.
Instead he was given a full state funeral and buried in the Republican blots of
glass Hyndman cemetery in Dublin, near his comrades.
Attending was president of the Republic of Ireland Ayman. Dillera now elderly,
who as a young man known casement, as he stood by his grave,
he said it required courage to do what Kaseman did.
And his name would be honored, not merely here,
but by oppressed peoples everywhere.
Even if he had done nothing for the freedom of our own country.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe also.
Please do check it out. Great sponsor Nord VPN that linked to below.
Thank you for watching.